hello and welcome to this video plane
dynamic pulse with black what did I get
another London system no this time it's
a trump c6 this is a funny line f3
Bishop d6 always leads to Oh what so
that's weird
okay don't think that can be very
dangerous
okay 92 you could simply capture but the
question is do I have something better
here or something more incisive creature
f6m the funny move attacking b2
I'm not sure that it's good though okay
I'm feeling adventurous let's do it
the critical reply is probably III
sacrificing a pawn okay didn't dead this
looks just fine gives me the bishop pair
for not much okay so there is no night
b5 because of Queen before check
I didn't even threaten all that much
okay what do you see going to play is
going to play III right so let's develop
and retreat yeah now I was thinking d5
just occupy the center okay maybe Bishop
d3 was more over this you okay now he
almost has to take on c6 oh yeah well
it's the wrong way to phrase it but
let's say if he doesn't I'm going to do
95 Oh Rick Rick
the night over to the kingside okay he
gives me the full center um yeah okay
five or Bishop no 95 I have to go each
five yeah more or less
I mean this is a nice center Bishop g4
now is a substantial threat I believe
and he for people really don't feel safe
well maybe he didn't didn't have a good
move but what now you know I can still
take on f3 the question is um if that is
actually the best move
I can't I can't start wait wait wait
wait wait what about 9065 could you have
done that I'm nothing I'm now starting
to think for real maybe you could have
played that right hmm interesting if I
go d4 now Knight takes e5 bishop d1
knight of seven yeah that works
Wow the ship g4 was actually rather
stupid okay I cannot play d4 so probably
have to grab him
not that I'm complaining but wait isn't
it does not treat Queens here Wow
okay um I'm not going to how do you how
do you do that it's let's let's first of
all kill off this night I'm not going to
take now now I'm attacking now kids so
look f4h for probably that should get
out of the way and this also the bishop
here is a very maybe it maybe c4 is an
idea to put it on to c5 but first of all
okay that's not possible anymore
interesting okay let's just close it
down I have enough things to do here
look F for rook f8 rook aged 4 and so on
I don't think you can defend that I
completely overlooked Knight takes e5 a
simple tactic
but it would have been bad and we say
anything
no probably not you think better than
this one okay maybe it's got age for
group of eight I came all so let's go
there and the next one the night has a
good spot on d3 absolutely but don't
show that you actually get down nights
you wanna have Luke Edgewater f4 back
wow that you can afford that it's it's
weird okay
[Music]
twenty seconds
mmm that is not the best move I just
went with the 20 seconds they made me
move I want to get into even more
substantial time problem Queen f6 was
probably already very strong he takes it
as just made and now I have a 4 coming
up
I mean the Queen is not helping in the
defense maybe it gets the King to age 1
to avoid immediate material loss okay
look at 5s winning do I have anything
better
look if for I am I don't need to even to
give him the default pawn the rook is
strapped on h2 so yeah keep it simple
there's no meteor does he have a check
no didn't see that one not good
technical plane got really irritated by
the time the time situation that's a
sailfin we have on might start to run
okay I get 15 seconds now a little bit a
little bit better so didn't see that one
you're not threatening to move the night
you know
let's bint okay now I did I didn't
convert it well but I was really a bit
irritated by the time
yeah there were quite a number of
mistakes they are from my heart I really
shouldn't overlook Knight takes e5 I
mean this is a comfortable position for
sure
okay this does and he took it 92 it
looks already quite disastrous we should
a six is strong okay you five assists
not bad
yeah and now okay Bishop g4 it's just a
stupid blunder it's just a stupid
blunder he can take a force stronger or
whatever I mean I've got a huge Center
and two bishops against who now I had
said is a win yeah Bishop g4 is too
stupid
I'm a mr. simple tactic him I mean this
is not worse probably for me but it's
not great either yeah if one he missed
it and now I recognized the thing and I
decided to take which is not ideal maybe
a queen move is what the engine suggests
is stronger keep the tension and
probably stronger and he definitely has
to play Queen takes a to get rid of the
Queen's then it's not even such a simple
technical task if you look at this like
Knight f5 I mean yeah they're better but
yeah I still have to win G takes just
looks like a terrible little game maybe
I should have gone c4 here I would have
been an interesting choice yeah making
this possible
okay Queenie six is not bad don't now I
make all the other
up to this point where he went queen a4
which is definitely not great and I'm
here at this moment I had this clock
ticking down and a plate which should be
aid simply to make a move on to only
later now he was taking a moment and
then I saw the idea Queen f6 in context
which is what happened to now and that
is yeah that that falls apart completely
so I could have probably checked mitogen
somewhere
Quincy one is basically wins everything
threatening hook on the first gym yeah I
didn't play it well here I was too
irritated by the time situation not sure
why rly I mean there was enough time and
here it's it's it's better with oh I was
just blundering into Ruby 8 and 96 wow I
made 5 in accuracy of 7 mistakes and 1
blunder that's terrible yeah I mean here
then just to show that was bad yeah now
I'm probably winning again but I was
pretty dreadful yeah couple of pretty
girls arrows ok guys thanks for watching